i just did this um
uh
series for pbs called road food yeah
jensen said to ask you about that we
traveled around the country
um
talking to
i mean honestly we were using food as a
as a window in the world so we're
looking at little you know regional
dishes
uh you know gumbo in louisiana for
example and we're using that as a as a
window into worlds where we'll i'll sit
down and literally
break bread with people and talk to them
about their lives and world
but it was actually really fascinating
because it was an excuse like you're
saying an excuse to sit down and listen
to people and talk to people and get to
know them that i wouldn't otherwise have
sat down with there just wouldn't have
been occasion but i also wouldn't have i
just wouldn't have made the space and
time for it yeah and so when you slow
down and you give some time and
attention and you actually
let yourself be present with someone
it's kind of remarkable like i
gleaned these little pearls of life
wisdom from
the guy who ran the little tortilla
factory in brownsville texas
um or you know or or the mayor of
tangier island in in the chesapeake bay
all of these individuals that i would
never have talked to
um were willing
to just open up and it was lovely it was
really fascinating i actually feel like
i learned about the human family through
that experience that's amazing and i
feel i feel the same way i think you
nailed it i think you know sitting with
someone there's like little morsels
little things that you've said little
things that other guests have said which
sort of help me or they help other
people who are listening
it's just like
a candid conversation open and i kind of
just you know throw [ __ ] at you and i i
find it to be fun i i was gonna quit
many times
the first 10 interviews i was like
nobody's listening nobody's listening
15.
you know 30 guests in i'm just like what
am i doing no one wants to hear me
interview people and then all of a
sudden i stuck with it
and i started to get more vulnerable and
i think that's when the show
got better when i started to open up and
i started to talk about my imperfections
which are
i have many
and i think that's you know people kind
of like that i open up like that and you
know even you you open up again about
your divorce and all the [ __ ] you're
going through and it's like wow
it's uh you know it's not all about
fluff and all about what you're doing
next and you know it's uh i don't know i
find it interesting to see that you know
we all go through ruts we all go through
tough times
you know